frédéric il y en a eu déjà plusieurs
exemples oui c'était en fait l'année
dernière c'était l'université du québec
à rimouski avec son institut des
sciences de la mer qui verse une
proposition de la pétrolière transcanada
pour créer une chaire de recherche sur
le béluga alors beaucoup ont trouvé ça
un peu suspect qu'une compagnie
s'intéresse subitement à la protection
de l'environnement alors qu'ils essaient
de mousser en fait le fameux projet de
pipeline énergie est donc finalement le
projet est tombé à l'eau un autre
exemple c'est celui de l'université
carleton à ottawa où ce personnage qui
s'appelle clinton avait proposé 15
millions $ procréer un programme de
maîtrise en sciences politiques sauf que
ce qu'ils voulaient c'était imposé ses
vues
quant à la sélection des candidats alors
carlton a dit non a quand même reçu
l'argent mais a réussi à faire changer
la corde ça c'était important et donc
c'est très difficile pour les
universités de dire non bien souvent à
des millions de dollars parce qu'un des
chaires de recherche évidemment c'est
très prestigieux dont il ya la tentation
de laisser un peu une perte de contrôle
en fait du sujet peut-être même avoir
des recherches qui sont dirigés pour
aller chercher cet argent là et des
chaires de recherche on a beaucoup
canada y en à 1666 dont 455 au québec
ouais vous le disais les contributions
privées ça vient quand même combler des
lacunes en termes de financement pour
lui il ya les universités oui céline
pascale de moins en moins d'argent
public en fait si on regarde en 1990 il
y avait 80 % des revenus de l'opération
qui était couvert par les fonds publics
aujourd'hui c'est 50 5% seulement
résultats ce qui en pâtit c'est la
recherche académique en fait ça a chuté
de 10% entre 80 et 2003 donc le besoin
forcément d'aller chercher de l'argent
ailleurs et donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que ça représente en fait le financement
privé pour la recherche universitaire
c'est 6% vous allez me dire c'est pas
beaucoup sauf que ça grandit de façon
exponentielle
il s'est quand même tout profit pour
certaines universités par exemple
l'université laval parvient à aller
chercher chaque année par le financement
privé jusqu'à 15 millions de dollars
c'est pas négliger un homme alors on
comprend l'intérêt pour les universités
mais pour les entreprises privées
surtout si à cette espèce de négociation
avec
université alors quel est leur intérêt
notamment en finançant des chaires de
recherche s'est notamment d'essayer de
faire un repérage sur les futurs
employés parmi les gens qui vont faire
ces recherches restées aussi au fait de
la recherche les ce qui se fait
qu'est-ce qu'il faut suivre renforcer
leur crédibilité en s'associant avec des
universités est aussi utilisé les
résultats d'études donc c'est une sorte
une situation qui peut être gagnant deux
gagnantes mais il faut que ce soit bien
encadré par les universités pour éviter
les éventuels perception de conflit
d'intérêts merci frédéric andré